star wars squadrons gameplay trailer
what's up reject nation excited to check
this out guys actually started up the
story mode of battlefront 2 this week
and simultaneously hopping around from
that to Jedi fall in order
I'm warrant of Jedi fallen order right
now I'm almost done with it I'm like
halfway through from being honest as I'm
catching up huts with Star Wars games
let's watch the gameplay trailer for
squadrons I love the trailer we got
earlier this week let's see what's in
store with this ea event going on
his Star Wars squadron earned its wings
in a single-player story spanning two
factions
[Music]
or er man knowing you then but I forgot
about that
[Music]
all the people of color in the entire
case Cassandra
you'll experience this world through
your cockpit the instrumentation in
front of you provides critical feedback
about power management targeting and
shields with a squadron of diverse
characters at your side ethnically
diverse scary
[Music]
stick together
shoot the balance of power in the galaxy
[Music]
fighters are the most flexible
interceptors are fast and highly
maneuverable
let's give ideal for hunting down your
opponent's star fighters perfect work
ships can keep allies safe and stock
done that's what we really want to be
biters if you've got a preferred
component you need something customized
I'll take care of you empires got a
class simply by playing the game from
cosmetics Joanne your ships fly fight
and survive
deal with you do a barrel roll
Star Wars multiplayer mode
[Music]
[Music]
four teams looking for an even greater
challenge it's time to prove yourself in
Star Wars watering signature mode
three battles are multi-stage conflicts
meet your team in the strategy file
complaints from HR for sexual harassment
no that's happening
[Music]
the ultimate goal target and destroy the
subsystems of your opponent's massive
fraction
stay together just right quickly by the
attention to detail my goodness oh we
are
[Music]
join the galaxy's finest
and it will be better than battlefront
true yeah Wow really is continuing rogue
squadrons right was the other one yeah
idea gosh rogue squad getting missing a
lot of those vibes mm-hmm but updated
for our timeline oh yeah and for those
who don't just want to play on the
lights yeah I don't really do online
gaming
unless I'm like with my friends in the
room all right I'm the last person you
want me to miss I don't need to yeah I'm
I like the games where I can just get
involved in this story like I always
choose to campaign modes and stuff I'm
never really doing like this is the kind
of game where I'm like oh for online
though yeah this is the ultimate way to
do it you will not want me on your team
all right everyone's gonna want to do
strategy and I'm not gonna listen I'm
just gonna want to flip and spin we're
not gonna really give two craps yeah I'm
saying everyone's just gonna choose the
fighter class it says you can strategize
before going into the match right yeah
there's like some nugget in there it's a
bet yeah which sounds awesome and smart
and then makes me wonder about like I
guess you could strategize against your
friends but can you strategize against
the computer it looks incredible like
yeah it's so detailed it feels like it's
salt on steroids man yes it's so extreme
I suck at the flight and all these games
but I love playing them that's why I
play by myself this really reminded me
of like a more manageable version of
that giant flight simulator game they
have it arcades that Star Wars with the
big dad on the front which is like
you'll just crash immediately a lot of
the time because the controls are so
sensitive that experience is like almost
to the point of having like a full-on VR
and like that especially going forward
John just this videogame but like this
is really accentuating how amazing that
looks like it's gonna be well to be in
the cockpit in a VR situation for a Star
Wars game sounds like a fantasy come to
life you know so like that in and of
itself just sounds worthy of at least
going to a friend's house and asked if
he could borrow his VR while you're
there to try out my haptic suits you can
feel it every time you good yeah very
great this looks like it's gonna deliver
a big part of what battlefront 2 was the
disappointment of I mean a lot of things
involving the gameplay aspect of it like
I said I'm always the guy who wants to
play for like the story about it and
they said here that there's a story mode
right yeah that sounds like what I'd be
buying came forward you know absolutely
I mean that's that's what kind of Drew
me further in was I saw this from the
outside of one who is this gonna be
mostly one of those games that
prioritizes online multiplayer and
doesn't really have much if you just
want to explore the right on your own or
you don't have friends to play with
these kind of games the online
experience of battling each other that's
where it's all gonna where the joy and
the long-lasting power of the game like
this will come from I can't recall the
last day I think it was rogue squadrons
right was the last time it was just you
know dogfighting yours the whole thing
is mainly space battles that's what's so
cool about this the it's space battles
come to life in the most lived in fully
realized experience you get within the
Star Wars universe now if they could
just do that for Star Fox but it's all
first-person point of view or can you
step out of the POV that's a good
question and I don't know if there's a
big difference in terms before yeah yeah
it might especially in VR but I wonder
if there's maybe some kind of difference
in a VR version if there's a different
version that necessitates that or not
but I mean it certainly looks like it's
very first-person oriented and I think
especially if they do want to lean
heavily on the VR aspect sure probably
would keep everything first-person I
mean third-person shooter is equally
tried and true and this also looks like
it's something that would lend itself to
like a lot of cool DLC because the thing
about this trailer specifically is it's
mostly like space and space debris but
Star Wars is also you know partly loved
for its breadth of worlds and different
types of places how great would it be if
you could pilot a Star Destroyer though
but that's the thing is like a game like
this yeah opens you up to every
possibility all sorts of DLC and and I
hope that they can bring more worlds or
you know different places for you to you
know check out within the unit
it seems really cool to get to explore
even though that's not what you're gonna
do yeah but just like any game that's
gonna put you especially in a VR
capacity right into the Star Wars world
I'll want to see the many places I can't
okay so your two main characters here
case Cassandra Imperial pilot and the
rebel pilot rau hi moon this is where we
get the diversity we've wanted yeah
right here yes okay yeah black lady
pilot versus an Asian man pilot oh man
Wow we think I've wanted there in the
universe I did find it funny the vol the
shots of humans we get in here more of
the people of color are in the Empire
yeah I felt kind of a strange about that
don't feel strange it makes sense though
they don't let that white guilt get to
you well I'm gonna play this game with
it's just my white guilt an entire
experience me like some kind of weird
reverse racist white knight well this
looks like it's gonna live up to the
height and then I feel like people will
be more satisfied with the gameplay here
than they were with Battlefront 2
I'm sure he is factoring in that
backlash experience as well guys what do
you think of it leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification building little
phone we got video what last but not
least Daniel Gallagher you know who's
really become a squadron that has gone
rogue oh it's Daniel Gallagher DG this
guy used to love chatting with me and
messages on patreon all the time
now I am assuming he has joined the
Imperials Tyrone Magnus's patreon page
you son of a bee why can't you pledge to
both of us it's not fair yeah be a rebel
and an imperial officer simultaneously
why choose this scenario were the rebels
yes we're the underdogs come here good
but Daniel man I hope you're doing well
I don't recall if you're actually a
gamer or not well there's a there's a
medical option in here being that he's
in the pharmaceutical game you could
bring that expertise to your team and
maybe I would know if you're a gamer if
you would still chat with me instead of
pledging to semblance of reality's page
Wow Wow I hope you're doing well in
Scotland they filmed the Batman there
you should be
I meant semblance of sanity